with around 50 000 rail workers going on
strike from tomorrow we're getting
warnings this morning that strikes may
cross over excuse me to teachers to
healthcare staff and airline staff as
well but how realistic a prospect is a
summer of discontent let's speak now to
mark zucker the uh general secretary of
one of the uk's largest trade unions the
public and commercial services union hi
good to see you thanks for joining us
summer of discontent what do you think
well i represent civil servants and
we've taken the decision that we are
balloting 150 000 civil servants for
industrial action in september
i think the national education union are
talking about balloting in the autumn as
well so i'm not sure about a summer of
discontent clearly we've got ray workers
on strike this week but what i am sure
about is that we will see high levels of
industrial action unless the government
recognize that frontline public sector
workers who kept the country running
during the pandemic
cannot be expected to have a two percent
pay raise when inflation is forecast to
be over 11 that is a historic cutting
living standards people cannot afford it
and therefore the government needs to do
something about it if they don't then i
do believe we are in for quite a lot of
industrial action
the government and indeed the governor
of the bank of england both saying that
um workers need to be realistic about
what they're expecting
otherwise the inflation will continue to
spiral
yes i i notice it's often rich people
tell those who haven't got much that
they've always got to be realistic
but what the government knows if you
take their own workforce is we have had
11 years
of pay cuts in real terms already so on
top of 11 years of pay cuts when the
average wage of the people i represent
is a fraction under 24 000 pounds a year
when tens of thousands of civil servants
have to claim in-work benefits because
their pay is already so low saying be
realistic just doesn't cut it because it
doesn't pay your fuel bill it doesn't
pay your council tax hike it doesn't
help you put food on the table only a
real terms pay raise does that and the
government must know that and the
governor of the bank of england must
know that so they just need to accept
that in this crisis those people who've
done so much to keep the country running
deserve to have a decent pay raise not
to take a further cut in their living
standards even if it feels uh the spiral
of inflation
well we're often told this wage is
fueling the spiral of inflation but at
the moment we know that's not the case
wages have nothing to do with the
current massive run on inflation and of
course if we think about it telling
workers that they are the ones who can
never have a pay raise really tells
people that the only way we can fight
inflation is that those who are
suffering most must take more pain and
frankly i saw your piece earlier okay it
was a fantastic piece if you are on
benefits or if you're on in work
benefits or if you are struggling
already to make ends meet
it cannot be right
that a train worker or a job center
worker or a refuge collector already
struggling haven't had a holiday for
years worrying about paying the bills
already i told you must pay the price to
keep inflation under control it's just
not acceptable and i don't think people
will accept it and i believe most
members of the public
will support frontline public sector
workers getting a decent pay raise but
but do you acknowledge um what the
governor of the bank of england is
saying because presumably he's in that
job because he knows what he's talking
about and unless we moderate our demands
for a pay increase that is lower than
inflation it will just continue to
spiral and make the problem worse
well it's it's easy for the government
bankruptcy to say that and i don't
frankly accept that i mean inflation
they're forecasting probably over the
next year or two will get back under
control but i think it's for the
government to find out ways of trying to
get inflation under control that doesn't
mean the people paying that terrible
price are teachers and nurses and job
center workers and the people who are
already struggling i mean i i'm often
told by people well if you go on strike
for more pay it means the price of food
goes up in the shops but the reality is
that the people we represent already are
struggling to pay for the things in the
shops and if they get a pay raise they
can manage their household bills in the
way that they choose but it can't be
right that the people with the least
are always told that they have to pay
the biggest price that's not fair and i
don't think people will accept it
do you think the rail strikes will go
ahead this week
well i'm not in the rmt and i'm not on
their negotiating team but it seems to
me all the mood music is that they will
go ahead and the thing that i would ask
viewers to just take on board is i've
heard grant shaps who i think is a
shocking secretary of state for
transport i've been unfortunate enough
to have to deal with him over our
dispute in the dvla last year he's a
dreadful minister
but i think that most people will accept
that that disruption is not down to the
fact that workers will now lose pay to
withdraw their labor it is down to the
fact that the government is allowing the
strike to go ahead instead of
intervening to give job security for
workers who worry about the future and
give our a workers a decent pay rise and
i for one
would be happily to be inconvenienced if
that inconvenience means that our
frontline rate workers men and women who
do such a fantastic job and work so hard
in the pandemic
that those people get a real living wage
increase and they get job security
um just before i let you go we did have
simon hart uh the chief secretary to the
treasury simon clark for give me on the
programme earlier today and i asked him
whether rail workers um have to suffer a
cut in pay he says we can't have
inflation busting pay increases the um
we tweeted that out the rmt union has
just retweeted that and said unless of
course it's for ceos because those
private school fields won't pay
themselves he added uh making uh light
uh or certainly um sneering at what the
government minister had to say is that
something is that an approach that you
would endorse
well i think there's a lot of hypocrisy
that is spoken by the government and to
be honest when there's an onslaught
demonizing women and men frontline
workers struggling so hard i think it's
entirely reasonable that their union
seeks to have their back and of course
it is true
that the people invariably telling those
with the least to tighten their belts
more are the ones who are incredibly
rich and we only have to look at our
chancellor the richest man in parliament
who is happy to tell people that they've
got to tighten their belts but he
himself doesn't know what it's like to
tighten his belt so if unions are
speaking it on behalf of their members i
back them and i back their dispute
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program thank you
thank you